I'm gonna I'm here to talk to you about
the mass shooting incident that occurred
here in the city of Monterey Park
this evening
or last night actually at approximately
10 22 pm
officers from the Monterey Park Police
Department responded to a local business
in the 100 block of West Garvey Avenue
in the city of Monterey Park regarding a
shots fired call
when officers arrived on scene they
observed numerous individuals patrons of
the location pouring out of location
uh
screaming the officers made entry to the
location
and located additional victims
the Monterey Park police fire department
responded to the scene and treated the
injured and pronounced 10 of the victims
deceased at the scene
there were at least 10 additional
victims that were transported to
numerous local hospitals and are listed
in various conditions from stable to
critical
the suspect fled the scene and remains
outstanding
uh anyone with information regarding uh
this incident we're asking them to call
LA Sheriff's homicide
at
323-890-5500 or if you prefer to remain
anonymous you can call Crime Stoppers at
800-222
-8477
Homicide Bureau is working closely
with Chief Scott Weiss and his agency at
the Monterey Park Police Department
we're working with the California
governor's office of emergency services
the Federal Bureau of Investigation LA
office
and numerous other law enforcement
agencies
with that I'll take a limited amount of
questions if anybody
no sir as far as motive goes it's too
early in the investigation to know what
the motive is
uh no sir not at this time no no
description on the suspect at this time
all I can tell you is that it was a
firearm that was used and no other
information on as far as the firearm
right now
the suspect is outstanding that's
correct
uh the location is uh there was Ballroom
it's like a ballroom dance location
uh we're aware of a uh an incident that
occurred in Alhambra and we have
investigators on scene uh trying to
determine if there's a connection
between these two incidents
video inside the Place yourself enough
so we're the investigators are are
working every lead on this case
obviously we have all our resources here
uh
a limited amount of resources we have
resources from various law enforcement
agencies we're reviewing all
surveillance video any surveillance
video
following All Leads so we're we're not
going to leave anything Unturned
uh no not at this time it's preliminary
we will have more information as more
information becomes available regarding
the suspect we'll put that information
out to you guys
uh yes sir we have uh 10 that are
deceased at the scene
and in additional We Believe at least 10
at local hospitals
everywhere anywhere from uh critical to
stable
as far as the suspect knowing any of the
victims it's too early in the
investigation we do not know that
information at this time
that's yeah we don't know if it's
targeted
uh no we don't know how old they are
um I'll just take two more questions and
and that's it we will update you guys
further uh this is just a preliminary
briefing we're going to have a lot more
information uh to share with you in the
in the future in the coming hours
possibly civilians have disarmed a
possible suspect that's something that
we're investigating and we'll have
additional information about that
we will look at every angle as far as
whether it's a hate crime or not it's
just too early in the investigation to
know whether this incident was a hate
crime or not
um you know I'm gonna have the chief
answer that question
um Chief sure
the festival that occurred Saturday also
extended to Sunday out of an abundance
of caution and in reverence for the
victims we are canceling the event
that's going to happen later today so
the lunar Festival here in Monterey Park
has been canceled
yeah uh just just two more questions
uh no not that I'm aware of uh I'm not
sure if there's any injuries or not they
were still investigating
any one other question
uh within the next few hours yeah uh
thank you everybody
sure Andrew Meyer
sure m-e-y-e-r
all right
uh Captain
um LA Sheriff's homicide
thank you everybody